uh i sat in a study a fellow i know uh
and he got some young americans for me
from all over the place in washington
okay
and i looked at them i listened to them
i i saw the passion in their eyes the
intelligence and the decency and i
thought
what's gone wrong in our system so i'm
not going to single out america because
we've got the same problem what's gone
wrong in our system that these people
even if they wanted to have a go would
feel that there was no pathway they're
intelligent they're driven they
understand freedom they're committed to
it they're ideal citizens the sort of
thing that the founding fathers
recognized was going to be needed in
leadership and which we're all saying we
want
do we want it enough to make pathways
what's why can't they get through in
this country
because they can't in australia that's
what they tell me what's stopping those
young people from pursuing careers in
leadership
meaning in politics
i don't think they're
stopping i will say there's more younger
guys that are stepping up today
that are being inspired to go into
politics there's a lot of good strong
capitalist young guys the the bench is a
very very deep bench but
they're in their
mid to late 20s early 30s so it's about
another decade
there's going to be a very very massive
deep bench of new superstars coming up
with backbones
but it's going to take about a decade or
so for them to come and by the way
here's
here's here's the the part of that with
the with the backbone situation
on uh these guys coming up
most people like i had a conversation
with a guy flew out and i sat down with
him and i said listen i think you got to
run for office i think you got to run
for governor and i had a meeting with
him and his wife and you know and i told
them why i think you should run for
office his wife says tell me how bad
it's going to be and i said very bad
they're going to come after you they're
going to come after your kids they're
going to come out to your family they're
going to come after everything you've
ever done
and some stuff's going to come out well
then that's why i said no but
you have to you have to understand that
none of us walk on water
like if people come after you and the
fear is that they're going to find
something in your uh in your what do you
call it in your skeleton they're going
to find some
okay
go ahead find the skeletons in my closet
yeah matter of fact i'll give you a
couple other bones here's you forgot
about these two bring these two up as
well i'll do some research for you and
you can so now what hey so here's what
you guys learned officially you learn i
don't walk on water you'll learn i have
a past you learn to have issues you
learn i'm not perfect you learn all that
stuff now how about i spend a half a
million dollars to investigate your past
with your marriage your past with your
ex your past with your taxes you're
passed with this do you want me to do
that how about i spend those resources
on you do you want me to put that on you
as well no no no no no how about i fire
some investigators to follow you for the
next two months i have the money to do
it how about if i do it then they say
well no that's not fair that's this
that's that no then it just means you
don't walk on water i don't walk on
water do you like my policies great vote
for me you don't leave me the hell alone
i'll go back to my life but we can't be
like
well what if they find out what i did
when i did this yeah what if we all find
out about what everybody did you know it
would be a very if if we all walked
around with all three biggest sins shown
above our forehead
we would be very disappointed with
people jonathan reber sax was a member
of the house of lords in england he
tragically died
quite recently but i did a podcast with
him and he said that no make the point
that no family no community no country
can work if you wash forgiveness out
and that's one of the great marks of the
viciousness and nastiness of our society
now we won't let bygones be bygones
and it doesn't work in your personal
life you know you're going to make a
mess somewhere in your marriage you're
going to do something wrong you've got
to say i'm sorry you're going to do it
with your kids you've got to say i'm
sorry most powerful moment with one of
my kids was and she was a very strong
personality little girl i said sorry one
day i said daddy did you say sorry i
said yeah i got that wrong
instant restoration you know um
and he made the point that our culture
now doesn't particularly the left this
nasty sensorius attitude that if you've
done one thing wrong that's it you're
cancelled you're on the way to the
guillotine you're done and i said well
what happens what can you hope for
if there's no forgiveness he said maybe
that people forget he said well that
doesn't work either because now social
media means they can bring up anything
from the past so maybe he had a point we
need to learn to recognize that none of
us are perfect and a little bit of
forgiveness goes a long way now that
doesn't mean you go live a reckless life
that doesn't mean you go live a hey
since i'm going to be forgiven i'm just
going to go be super reckless and do
whatever i want to do and do whoever i
want to do and you know be that kind of
a life that's also not the point my
point isn't that my point is
try to live a strong life
back it up with honor strong values
principles
loyalty dependability reliability all of
that stuff but at the same time
you're not going to be expecting
somebody that's going to be walking on
water i think we've got plenty of people
that should be running that don't want
to run so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]